You get to the end of the call. Everything's good
Business owners like you're like, yo, I just need a credit card, you know, he's good to go. Oh, yeah
Um, I don't do credit cards. I'm just gonna send you a PayPal
I'm sure you take out the PayPal, right?
And I know I've been I've been like it's been a while but I know a couple years ago
I would have said yeah, I guess that's okay. He'd send me a PayPal
You know what you should say and what you're gonna start saying is like no, I don't actually don't unfortunately you could say it
However, you want but unfortunately, I don't take PayPal credit cards the only way I'm not gonna be chasing you around
I got too many people I'm working with this is too my time is too valuable and so is yours
I got to keep a credit card on file. That's a deal breaker. I apologize. I gotta keep a credit card on file
Scariest shit to say right but I promise you they'll respect you and if they're actually sold they give you the credit card
Period. I have a guy I kid you not have a client right now
that he signed a deal before the New Year and
I said I he signed it we're good to go and I sent him a credit card authorization and he said hey
Can I just give you my bank account and dude? I have I hate bank account stuff because then on stripe when the payment declines
It's this whole thing and it takes a while to get paid. I just don't like it. I
Want to get paid today. I said we don't take we don't take bank account. Sorry, and I kid you not
I walked away from that deal. I
Literally told him that like I can't take anything besides a credit card period and
It took another four weeks almost a full month of
Me I just I wouldn't take it and it took four more weeks before I finally got his credit card
He went to the bank and got a card
Just so he could pay for leads. Okay, so he wasn't bullshit. I thought he was lying
He's like I don't have a credit card for this business. I want to put under this business
He wouldn't got a credit card because I just my time is too valuable. I'm not gonna mess with it
So that's an example people are gonna ask. Hey, you know, I don't I don't like giving out my credit card
can I just give you my PayPal or
Or this one you get more often. Yeah, I don't I don't want to have my credit card on file
Can you just send me the invoice?
Wait, will you just send me the invoice? Sorry? I got a itch on that
Well, you guys just send me the invoice every month and I'll just pay it now. Sorry. We just have it
This is how I respond so are we just have it in our system automatically like keep in mind
I'm doing this with 50 60 companies. I can't go in and do this every single month
So I I'll send you the first one as the invoice, but after that it's gonna automatically bill cool
Cuz then what happens is that once they fill in the information, it's gonna lock their card and file and I just I'm straight with them